this video is brought to you by
expressvpn learn more at expressvpn calm
/ wisecrack
[Music]
whatsup wisecrack jared again black
mirror recently returned to Netflix with
its 5th season and the response has been
mixed or at least more mixed than usual
many have noted that the show feels
different and they're not wrong after
diving into fan reactions it seems like
the main criticisms of this season are
first that technology doesn't drive the
plot of the episodes like in previous
seasons second that it isn't giving us
the same head-scratching questions at
use - and third that it feels like the
show lost its edge and how far it's
willing to go but do these criticisms
hold up we're gonna find out in this
wisecrack edition on black mirror season
5 deep or dumb and of course spoilers
ahead for all seasons but before we get
into it I want to give a shot to this
week's sponsor expressvpn a VPN is a
Virtual Private Network which encrypts
all your online actions and protects
your information from getting stolen you
can safely login to all your favourite
platforms without the fear of having
your Netflix password stolen or worse
your banking info expressvpn has an app
for every device who you are even
protected on the go if I'm out and about
and out of data I'll try to log into a
public Wi-Fi hotspot so it's really
comforting to know that evpn will
protect me if i accidentally try to
connect to a fake hotspot a hacker can
easily steal your data and then sell
your info to the highest bidder online
whether it's to ad companies or someone
on the dark web so it's good to know
that with a VPN I'm protected expressvpn
has the fastest speeds of any other VPN
and is less than $7 a month with a
30-day money-back guarantees so take
back your internet privacy today and
find out how you can get three months
free by clicking the link in the
description or by going to expressvpn
comm slash wisecrack and now back to the
show let's start with the first episode
striking vipers tells the story of
estranged friends Danny and Carl who
rekindled their friendship and much more
through a VR video game called striking
Vipers a morally ambiguous virtual fling
ensues but Danny breaks it off out of
respect for his marriage unable to find
the same kind of passion with another
partner Karl attempts to revive their
digital romance they eventually decide
to test their attraction in real life
two lackluster results and then get into
a real fight that blows the lid off
their affair a compromise has reached at
the end wherein Danny and Karl can hook
up online once a year and Danny's wife
can go to an actual bar and bang an
actual dude which feels a little
unbalanced or is it so let's dive into
the first issue technology no longer
drives the episodes in striking Vipers
were presented with a state of domestic
equilibrium that is upset once Karl
introduces the TCK our virtual reality
system into Danny's life and this basic
premise drives the entire drama of the
episode
Danny's infidelity whether or not our
two players have feelings for each other
and so on however if we compare it to
the episode the entire history of you we
can see a slight variation on the black
mirror formula like striking Vipers this
episode introduces a new gadget and
frames it around a couple struggling
with infidelity expanding how we
document our lives on social media the
grain is an implant that stores a
perfect record of everything you've ever
done for instant recall it even shares
some of the same visual cues as striking
Vipers in the entire history of you the
application of the grain technology
escalates as our protagonist uses it to
uncover more and more troubling elements
of the past initially it's used to
reflect on a job interview or show off a
vacation then it's used to adjudicate a
fight I didn't mean that you're a [ __ ]
I'd like you to erase that you're a
[ __ ] until finally at the end our
protagonist is physically forcing
someone to relive their most intimate
moments striking Vipers however
introduces the morally ambiguous
application of technology at around the
20-minute mark and the rest of the
conflict escalates only within the
relationship dynamics in other words the
premise that you can now use vr gaming
to have sex via avatars is established
early on and the ways in which the
technology is used doesn't escalate save
for the dude who screws a polar bear
still striking Vipers is probably the
most classic black mirror of the three
episodes and that's because the
technology does create a premise which
drives a series of philosophical
questions about said technology
does romance mean in a world where VR
can beam ultra-realistic images into
your brain as porn gets more and more
sophisticated at what point does it
become cheating but it's not cheating
this is it's not real what does that VR
mean for sexuality when a straight dude
can embody a female avatar and have
virtual hetero sex with another straight
dude or more broadly how does VR
technology affect our perception of self
if Carl is attracted to other men but
only when inhabiting a female avatar can
virtual reality allow us to access
previously dormant aspects of our self
or are these aspects exclusive to the VR
experience the influence of digital
avatars on our meatspace selves is a
pretty fascinating area of study in the
book infinite reality authors Jim Blas
kovitch and Jeremy bailenson details
several studies exploring VR
psychological effects and how VR does
alter our perception of self both while
and after using it for instance people
inhabiting a taller avatar feel more
confident during and after using VR to
having an attractive avatar makes people
more warm and social inhabiting older
avatars makes younger people more
concerned about saving money and using a
physically fit avatar makes people want
to exercise more to be fair the book
isn't about screwing people via digital
proxies but the larger point can help
inform our understanding of the episode
as striking Viper's suggests the effects
of VR aren't just limited to the game
both Carl and Danny's IRL relationships
suffer and it makes them ask basic
questions about who they are as they
both have to consider if they truly love
each other outside of the digital world
they don't which raises the question of
how much our physical bodies shape our
relation to the world when we enter into
a new corporeal form
do we also inhabit a whole new identity
this more or less speaks to a mind-body
exploration but more precisely a mind
avatar one but as many have pointed out
the episode doesn't offer any firm
answers to any of the questions raised
about identity and part of that leads
into the third criticism that the show
has lost its teeth because it doesn't
offer any answers it's hard to see it as
giving any biting comment
young technology whereas the entire
history of you ends in the ruin of our
protagonists marriage striking vipers
ends with a more or less optimistic
state of equilibrium although this may
be a new flavor of black mirror only
occasionally seen in the likes of San
Junipero its lack of soul-crushing
pessimism doesn't necessarily make it a
bad episode although it breaks some
elements of the black mirror formula
it's still an episode with big questions
to ask about real scientific and social
issues so this episode gets a wisecrack
certified deep the second episode
smithereens tells the story of rideshare
driver Chris who kidnaps an intern from
the Twitter stand in smithereen holding
him to ransom so he can speak to the
company's Jack Dorsey esque CEO
Billy Bower when they're finally on the
line with each other Chris explains how
he killed his wife in a car crash
because he was distracted by the app
with his mission fulfilled Chris tries
to kill himself but the intern
intervenes in the scuffle a Police
sniper fires a Chris the end
so first up does technology Drive the
episode well sort of the main plot may
seem like a regular kidnapping story but
Chris's ability to get hold of the right
people at smithereen is entirely
dictated by his access to a phone your
phone where's your phone a symmetrically
these smithereen technology has
immediate access to everything about him
pretty immediately this discrepancy
often drives tension as Chris uses
smithereen to find out they've been
spying on him bringing him ever closer
to the edge the big distinction between
this and other black mayor episodes is
that we're not constantly introduced to
novel applications of some future
technology in order to escalate the
conflict it's also worth noting that
this episode takes place in the recent
past so there's nothing really sci-fi
here which is fine but if that's the
premise then you hope the show has
something profound to say about the
technology we currently have
unfortunately this is where some people
feel smithereens is at its weakest so
does it give us a good philosophical
question or two a lot of the criticism
leveled at this episode comes from the
twist the revelation that Chris crashed
the car and killed his wife because he
was checking his phone so I've seen this
as a sort of don't text and drive PSA
which is not
original or interesting as entertainment
but beyond that there might be a much
more foreboding message namely how much
control large Silicon Valley companies
have over our lives and society in
general using data smithereen can
discover everything about Chris long
before the police or even the FBI listen
Ms when we've identified the suspects 33
years old he has a smithereen profile
also Billy Bower gleefully invokes a god
mode on his laptop it's exact function
is unclear but will take a hint from the
word god far from being just a criticism
of how we use social media the episode
is a critique of society's dependence on
it as a whole and the terrifying power
of these companies wield this is framed
by a grieving mother looking for answers
about why her daughter killed herself by
trying to figure out her social media
passwords I'm a mom you'd think they'd
give me the password to my own choice as
a cat but no of course the companies
won't help her meaning a faceless tech
company knows more about her daughter
and her death than she does but then
there's Bauer's speech about him losing
control the company alongside Chris's
confession about the crash and its
causes I'm like some kind of both
frontman now as a climax these two
speeches may not have the same
everything's gone to [ __ ] and we're all
doomed aspect that other black mirror
stories have but it has a lot more
emotional bite to it that's equally hard
to ignore the show doesn't just lay the
blame solely at the feet of a smartphone
user when things go wrong as the show
hints it's as much the fault of the
unchecked optimization for addictiveness
and rampant privacy invasion which has
created a world where phone companies
themselves have to make PSAs telling you
to turn your phone off when driving it
might not be offering any new
philosophical questions or
interpretations of technology but it
speaks volumes to modern frustrations
around corporate control for that reason
we're giving this episode eight soft
deep well let me rephrase that we're
giving it a deep enough rating in the
final episode Rachel Jack and Ashley -
Miley Cyrus plays Ashley OH a thinly
veiled version of Hannah Montana who
feels trapped at her pop persona and
suffers from depression meanwhile
superfan Rachel gets a robot version of
Ashley oh that malfunctions when it
learned
that Ashley is in a coma brought about
by her evil aunt who drugged her to take
control of her creative output the robot
is an exact copy of Ashley's
consciousness and asks Rachel and her
sister jack for help to free the real
Ashley they take the robot along save
the real Ashley and expose her evil aunt
as we've mentioned in typical black
mirror the technology is what pushes the
story along whether that's the exercise
bike economy a memory reading implant or
making a sex doll based on your dead
boyfriend's tweets
obviously this episode has technology
the Ashley robot it's consciousness some
software that can write songs from brain
scans and so on but there's one big
problem the tech isn't actually
important to the plot let me give you a
little scenario if in nose-dive we
swapped out the people rating software
for anything else say a central written
record of whether or not people hate you
the episode would not be the same you
could not make a cautionary tale about
how people's judgments become
increasingly dangerous without the
technology that amplifies those
judgments nor could you comment on
people's online personas versus offline
that's how a ton of good smart sci-fi
works
you can't remake Star Trek by replacing
a starship with a Honda Civic conversely
if you gave John wick a laser Gatling
gun we wouldn't say it's about
technology like black mirrors that's
because whether he's using a hunting
knife a gun a book a pencil or some yet
undiscovered killing device the point is
still that someone killed Keanu Reeves
his dog
Rachel Jack and Ashley - falls into that
ladder camp it's essentially kids get
roped into a pickle break into some
stuff do something important and all
become friends whether they have
slingshots or a sentient doll is besides
the point
you can replace or reframe a lot of the
tech in this episode and still tell the
same story take for instance the brain
scanning songwriter if they just stole
her diary to write songs the plot is
functionally the same there's a fancy
computer that rewrites her angsty songs
to be poppy which a human could have
done also there's a hologram which we've
already done to poor Tupac that one is
harder to extricate from the plot but
the basic question of what happens when
an artist loses control of their
intellectual property doesn't really
need tech to play out but we'll get
there Ashley - isn't about electric
Mouse
Hatcher's robot dolls or songwriting
software it's about two lonely teenagers
and an exploited popstar looking to fill
a void in their lives but even if the
technology isn't driving the plot it's
still a big part of it so what is it
saying about the technology the idea
that a piece of software can be used to
extract and rewrite something as
abstract and creative as a piece of
music is certainly interesting but it's
actually a little behind the times when
it comes to the music industry
exploiting artists the question of
artists not owning their music or
likeness has been going on in the courts
for 50 years or more Michael Jackson
bought the publishing rights to the
entire Beatles back catalogue Amy
Winehouse never consented to the
releases of the demos and unreleased
tracks that made up her posthumous album
lioness and the late dr. John had songs
released under his name without consent
that the label hired an impersonator to
sing intellectual property disputes
don't require a futuristic technology to
tell their story so what about the
question of a consciousness being
trapped inside of a device well this has
been better explored in several episodes
before but most notably in white
Christmas the second of the stories and
white Christmas shows a consciousness
being trapped inside a digital egg that
is tortured into submission to act as an
electronic home assistant at the
beginning of story were shown how
painful and disorienting the process of
removing the cookie containing the
digital self is and the snapshot of the
existential questions you'd ask if your
consciousness had been duplicated oh my
god am i dead no no the idea of
maintaining consciousness outside of the
body and the questionable ethical and
moral areas is at the center of why
Christmas but left unexplored in Ashley
to the robot and the real Ashley meet
each other with no existential crises at
first we expect everything to go
horribly wrong with the Ashley - and for
there to be awful consequences to this
technology but that's not what happens
instead we get a fun high style
adventure that abandons most of the tech
in favour of a car chase so if it isn't
as much about the technology and what
it's saying about tech isn't very new or
interesting then it surely must have a
sobering finale right something like
Ashley doesn't make it and the aunt
makes billions off her brain or the
robot having to create its own existence
but unfortunately not Ashley - has the
most
the happy ending of all three which is
probably what pissed so many people off
about it there are no profound lessons
about the digital future to be learned
but maybe something to be learned about
how we interact with one another in real
life it's just a fun episode but that
reason we're giving this one a hard dumb
but that doesn't mean we didn't enjoy it
since it began black mirror has
constantly delivered a sense of
catharsis about where technology is
taking us but with things like China's
social rating system actually happening
maybe the show has realized that we
can't put the lid back on the Pandora's
box of technology so instead it's trying
to offer suggestions on how to navigate
life in our modern digital dystopia
there's no point in telling people to be
aware of what technology might one day
mean when we're already hyper aware of
those dangers and in some cases living
them instead Charlie Brooker seems to be
giving us more of an emotional bite that
might help us better understand our
current digital domain for that reason
we're gonna give season 5 as a whole a
soft deep rating because you know what
at least it's trying keep doing you
black mirror but what did you think wise
crack was the latest season deep or dumb
leave us your thoughts in the comments
and we'll see you next time thanks to
all our patrons who support the channel
and our podcasts don't forget to hit
that subscribe button and before you go
I want to give into the shout out to
expressvpn a VPN encrypts all your
online actions and protects your
information from getting stolen getting
a VPN has changed the game we use it
every day at the office and since they
have the best speeds it doesn't even
disturb our day-to-day internet usage
you can get expressvpn for less than
seven dollars a month with a 30-day
money-back guarantee and right now you
can get three months for free by going
to the link in the description or by
going to expressvpn comm slash wisecrack
thanks again to expressvpn
and as always thanks for watching guys
peace
[Music]